بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
ولا تجسسوا ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضه
قد سبق القول
بمعنى قول الله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن ان بعد ان بعض الظن
اثم
والله عز وجل نهى عن الكثير
يستيقن المرء من اجتناب
ما هو اثم من الظن وهو ظن السوء
والظن الذي لا يوافق الحق ولا يوافق
الواقع
وهذا الظن قد سبق ان ذكرنا
ان الظنون كثيره ومختلفه
من الظنون
ما تدخل النار والعياذ بالله
ومن الظنون ما تخلد في النار
فذلكم ظنكم الذي ظننتم بربكم ارداكم
اصبحتم خاسرين
فثما اناس ظنوا ظنون بالله سبحانه وتعالى
وجعل الله السبب الرئيسي في خلودهم في
نيران جهنم والعياذ بالله هذه الظنون التي
كانت
تجاه الله سبحانه وتعالى التي لا توافق
الحق ولا توافق الواقع ولا توافق التنزيل
وانما هي اشبه بالاوهام المتبوعه
وكذلك الظن قد يكون
سيئا من المسلم تجاه سلفه يعني الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم والصحابه وهذا قد كان من
بني اسرائيل
وقد كانوا يظنون الظنون بانبيائهم
حتى حملهم
او حملتهم هذه الظنون على قتل
الانبياء والعياذ بالله
وكل ما جاءكم رسول بما لا تهوى انفسكم
استكبرتم ففريق كذبتم وفريقا تقتلون وهذا
كله من سوء الظن ومن اتباع الهوى
ومنه كذلك ما ظنوه بموسى عليه السلام حين
ما كان يامرهم امرا من الله
قال ان الله يامركم ان تذبحوا بقره قالوا
اتتخذنا هزوا
ولا اعوذ بالله ان اكون من الجاهلين
وكذلك ما ظنوه
في موسى عليه السلام من العيه الخلق حيث
قالوا ان موسى قادر
وهو
مرض يكون فيه
خصيتي الرجل
فبراءه الله سبحانه وتعالى مما قالوا وهذا
من سوء ظنهم
وما هو
الذي يكون من المسلم والنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول لا تتبعن سنن من كان قبلكم وفي
لفظ سنن من كان قبلكم حدو القذه بالقذه
حتى لو دخلوا جحر ضب لدخلتموه
فقالوا اليهود والنصارى يا رسول الله قال
فمن
يعني فمن يكون اذا والمقصود باليهود
والنصارى الذين ضلوا من اهل الكتابين وليس
المؤمنين الصالحين منهم
منهم امه مقتصده يقول الله وكثير منهم
فاسقون
فهؤلاء الذين فاسقوا من اهل الكتاب حذر ان
الله من فسوقهم وهذا الفسوق هو ما ذكره
الله في القران من
اعتدائهم وتجاوزهم حدهم وما شابه ذلك
فالله عز وجل
يذكر
مسائل من مسائل اهل الكتابين من قبلنا ممن
ضلوا وذكرهم الله واستفتح كتابه بقوله غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يقرا ذلك على
الصحابه ثم يقول لا تتبعن سنن من كان
قبلكم حذو القذف بالقذه فماذا نفهم من ذلك
نفهم من ذلك انما ذكره الله تعالى من ذنوب
واعتداءات اهل الكتابين من قبلنا فهي لنا
ايش يعني لنا يعني هي تحذير تحذير لنا
وسيقع من يقول بمثله في هذه الامه
كثر ذلك او ندر لكنه سيكون وسيقع وهذه
الامه كبيره عظيمه مجيده واسعه واسعه
الافق في الزمن وفي المكان
وسياتي من من ينتمي الى هذه الامه من
الجاهلين والسفهاء ممن يتبعون
زخرف القول والغرور
فيقعون في امثال هذه الاخطاء التي حذرنا
الله سبحانه وتعالى منها في كتاب في كتابه
المنزل
وبعض المسلمين قد يظن ظنونا برسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم خاطئه وهو قد لا يتنبه
لذلك فبعض الناس مثلا يسيء الظن
بالرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم واصحابه
ولكنه لا يدري انه يسيء الظن فقد يكون
سوء الظن هذا بان يظن ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وصحابته كانوا جماعه
غير متفقهين
قليليه العلم
وانما يمشون على سلامه الفطره والتسليم
ولا يتمعنون فيه
تنزيل الله سبحانه وتعالى حتى ان ذلك
الظن الخاطئ الردي قد صدر من بعض اهل
العلم حتى ان بعض العلماء في التاريخ
اشتهر عنه
القول بان علم السلف اسلم وعلم الخلف اعلم
واحكم وهذا كلام باطل وقد رد عليه العلماء
قد الف ابن رجب رحمه الله
كتابا حافلا في فضل علم السلف على الخلف
وبوب ابوابا ومن هذه الابواب مثل
من فضل علم السلفي على الخلف قله
كلامهم وكثره معاني هذا الكلام مثلا هذا
دليل على ماذا على العلم المفرط
على العلم الواسع الذي يستطيع ان يتكلم
بايجاز واذا تمعنت وجدت ان كلامه جامعا
مانعا هذا علم هذا لا ياتي الا بعد
جهد جهيد ووقت مديد
وعزم من حديد وتوفيق من الله العزيز
الحميد وعلى كل حال فضل علم السلف على
الخلف قد يظن بعض المسلمين
بسلفه السوء قل هذا والجماعه يعني ما
كانوا يعرفوا اللي احنا بنعرفه ما كانوا
متفتحين زي ما احنا متفتحين كانوا متقدمين
زي ما احنا متقدمين
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم قد يسمع بعض
احاديث يستنكرها
يقول مثلا اذا وقعت ذبابه في
اناء احدكم فليغمسها ثم ليلقي بها وليشرب
فان في احدى جناحيه
او في احد جناحيه
باحدى جناحيه داء وفي الاخرى دواء حديث
صحيح البخاري
فيقول ما هذا يعني من الذي يغمس ذبابه في
الشراب ثم يشرب هذا يعني
هذا كلام كلام
ادري ان بعض المسلمين
التبس عليه دينه وادري ان بعض الناس قد
يستعجل في الحكم وبعض الناس قد ينفي هذا
قل هذا ما قاله الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
بناء على ماذا يكذب جميع اللي في الاسانيد
ويكذب البخاري ويكذب جميع العلماء اللي
نقلوا لماذا لانه لا يتصور ذلك
كان كان الصحابه رضي الله عنهم الاشياء
لها قيمه لها قيمه
يعني كان الواحد يتعب ساعتين ثلاثه خمسه
عشان يروح على البير يستسقي
فياتي بالماء ما يفتح الحنفيه وهي الماء
بارد يعني زلال ما شاء الله يشرب لمنه
ينسطح ما كان هذا الامر كان اللي بده يشرب
مي بده يروح وبده يوقف في الطابور وبده
يزاحم الناس وبده يجيب مي وبده يرجع لبيته
ويحملها المي بده ينام بده نومه بعده
فطبعا انت قاعد في الصحراء وذبابه وقعت
فيها الماء شو تسوي ترمي المي كلها يعني
كلام
فيه قصور في التصور فيه قصور في التصور
بعض الناس يظن ان الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم والصحابه استطاعوا اتقان الاسلام نعم
اتقان الاسلام
للفراغ كان عندهم فراغ اما نحن فهذه اشياء
مستجده صح ولا لا يا شيخ انا مشغول ما
بقدر يجي على صلاه الجمعه عنا شغل وعندنا
مدرسه وعنا اشياء حياه ما عنا يعني الواحد
يقطع وقته يجي يقعد في الجامع لا بدك تيجي
وهذا التصور جاء من ماذا صدر عن سوء فاهم
يظن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم والصحابه
فارغين قاعد الواحد تحت ظل هالشجره وبستنى
بس في الاذان
مع انه كان
كان الواحد منهم يعمل يعمل طيله النهار
صباحا مساء بس عشان يثبت لاهله ولنفسه
اساسيات العيش
الاشياء اللي انا وانت ميسره لنا المي
تفتح الحنفيه هي المي وخذ لك هالخمسين
دولار وميض طول النهار والليل ماشي وكهربة
ما شاء الله ولا بدك تقعد تسوي في نار ولا
تجمع حطب اضوي هل هذا وادفع لك اربعين
دولار في الشهر وهاي النار بتضل شغاله
عندك ليل نهار واتفق يا عمي والبروده كمان
روح عركان في الصيف يا حرام خذ ماشي وبدك
اكل بدك تروح بس بدكش تروح كل يوم تدور
على اكل شو هالشغله لا روح مره في اسبوعين
وهي عندك ثلاجات ما شاء الله حط في
الثلاجه وبعدين حتى بدكش تطبخ مش مشكله
بنطبخ لك اياه وبعدين انت بس حطه في
المايك وهو يسخن يا عمي كمان شو بدك
بدك تتحمم اغتسل خمس مرات في النهار وما
في شغله اسمها سخن ميه ومش سخن ميه ادخل
في هالدش وتحمم اربعين خمسين دقيقه وانت
بس تحت الدش وبنبيع لك يا عمي دش بيمر
رجلك ظهرك وبسويلك كل الاشياء الاشياء غير
موجوده في وقت الصحابه كان الواحد منهم
عشان بس يوكن لوك متعيش
يدور وين بدي اجيب خبز وبدنا نخبز اليوم
يوم كبير بدنا نخبز اليوم روح اجمع حطب
هات عاد وشغل هالحطب وهالطابون والناس
يتجمع وشغله كبيره هذي كانت بدهم يخبزوا
مساله ليست كايامنا
على فوق كل هذا
فتحوا الدنيا
ونشروا فيه العلم والنور والعدل
واحنا كل هذه الاشياء موجوده عنا والواحد
منا مش عارف يعني
يقوم على صلاه الفجر يقول لك يا عمي شغل
عندي شغل كيف اقوم على صلاه الفجر وانا
معيش الا هالساعتين انام فيها
ويا عمي كيف بدي اقطع الشغل ويجي على صلاه
الجمعه عندي عمال وعندي وعندي وعندي وعندي
محلات كانه ما في حدا عنده محلات الى اخره
ياتي هذا من ماذا من سوء الظن سوء الفهم
هؤلاء جماعه كانوا مشغولين اكثر من شغلنا
بعشرات المرات لكن
تفرغوا لقيام الليل وصيام النهار كان
عندهم حزم
لذلك نفضل علم السلف على الخلف ونفضل عمل
السلف على الخلف ومن هذا جاء قول النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم لا تصبوا لا تسبوا
اصحابي والذي نفسي بيده لو انفق احدكم مثل
احد
ذهبا ما بلغ مده احدهم ولا نصيفه ولا حتى
نصف مت
وهذا قاله لبعض الصحابه يعني هذا الحديث
جاء قولا من الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
لصحابه يدافع عن فئه اخرى من الصحابه فما
ظننا بانفسنا لابد للامه ان تقدر وان تعظم
سلفه
ولابد للامه ان تعظم وتقدر الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
فان تعظيم من حوله تعظيم تعظيم له اذا
عظمنا اصحابه فهذا يدل على رجل مجيد
صاحب بصيره والله عز وجل لم يحطه الا به
بالاكابر من الناس ولذلك يقول رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم خير الناس قرن ثم
الذين يلونهم ثم الذين يلونهم وقال في
حديث واثله ابن الاسقى عند احمد وغيره
يقول
والله لا تزالون بخير ما دام فيكم من راني
وصاحبني والذي نفسي بيده لن تزالوا بخير
ما كان فيكم من راني من راى من راني وصاحب
من صاحبني
والله لن تزالوا بخير ما كان فيكم من راى
من راى من راني وصاحب من صاحب من صاحبني
هذه قرون مفضله لا تدرك في
الفضيله وليس ذلك لانهم متفرغين واصحابي
يعني بس فطر سليمه وماشيين ولو كانوا في
احوالنا كنا احنا احسن منهم لا هذا سوء ظن
اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن
وهذا سوء الظن ماذا
يصنع بعمل الانسان يده هو العمل
يده هو العمل
وكذلك سوء الظن
بالامه قد يقع سوء ظن
بالامه والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في صحيح
مسلم يقول من قال هلك الناس فهو
اهلكهم وفي لفظ اهلكهم
الفرق بين اهلكهم واهلكهم يعني هو اهلك
واحد فيهم
واهلكهم يعني هو من الاسباب اللي هلكت هذه
الامه من هذا الفكر
هو الذي اهلكهم هكذا يقول بعض الناس تجري
على السنه بعض الالفاظ وهي في الحقيقه لو
تمعنا النظر فيها فانها لا لا لا تنبغي
مثل يقول والله انا
خبرتي مع العرب كيت وكيت خبرتي مع
المسلمين انا بروح على النصراني ولا اروح
على المسلم
نسمعها كثير دائما بنسمع
هل العله في نصب هذا المسلم واحد مسلم نصب
علي هل العله اسلامه ولا العله تربيته مش
مربى هذا قول انا بروح عند المحترمين
ما تقول ما بروح عند المسلمين
الذي دفعه الى هذا هل هو الاسلام الذي
دفعه والى هذا حتى تقول
الغير المسلم احسن منه
عكس ضد الكلام وهذا سوء ظن بالمسلمين
الامه
لا
يا عمي الامه الاسلاميه الامه واسعه فيها
خير وفيها من هو دون ذلك
ونحن نرجو دائما توبه الذين هم دون ذلك
ونخشى عليهم
ونسند ونؤيد الصالح منهم
ونسند ونؤيد الصالح منهم انصر اخاك ظالما
او مظلوما
المؤمن مراه اخي اذا اخوك المسلم نصب عليك
وانظر في نفسك برضو
لماذا هذا الرجل فعل هذا هل هو محتاج مثلا
هل هو يعني ساظنه ظنه بي هل كذا الواحد
يتساءل يسال نفسه ما فيها شيء هذا تواضع
ويريد احدنا ان يكون من جمله
الاجوبه ومن جمله
الاصلاح ولا يريد ان يكون من جمله الخطا
الانسان يحسن الظن بغيره
وقد يسيء احدنا الظفا لبعض الاشاعات التي
تشاع
وخاصه في هذا الزمان الاخير
فان
سفهاء القوم
كلامهم مسموع اكثر من كلام العلماء
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم نبه على ان
هذا من من ايات الساعه ان يكثر
خطباء وان يقل الفقهاء وياتي على الناس
سنوات
خدعات هكذا في حديث معاذ
يصدق فيها الكاذب ويكذب فيها الصادق
ويؤتمن فيها الخائن ويخون فيها الامين
وينطق فيها الرويبضه قالوا ما الرويبض
الرويبض يا رسول الله قال الرجل
التافه يتكلف يتكلم في امر العامه
هذا واقع تفتح التلفاز بجوز واحد في المئه
ممن يمرون عليك له حق واهليان يتكلم فيما
هو يتكلم فيه هذه مصيبه لماذا لان هذا
الهذيان الذي املاه عليه شيطانه فانه
سيمليه علينا باحلى صوره
احلى صوره
واحلى طراز
وافخم
بيان
زخرف القول تزيين الشيطان له التزيين
ياتي يتكلم في امور وقد يستهزئ من العلماء
عندك جماعه شغلهم الشاغل بس يشغل
يشغل في اليوتيوب او هذه الاشياء
يستهزئ بها للعلم يقول هذا العالم الفلاني
قال كذا
لنستمع الى ما يقول وبعدين يقعد يتهكم
حتى لو كان مخطئا لماذا اساءنا الظن انه
مدفوع له هذا تبع مصاري وهذا تبع الى اخره
حتى ان احدهم قد يستهزئ باسلوب العالم في
الكلام
حتى لو كان مخطئا حتى لو كان على ضلاله
فان هذا لا يستهزئ به
لا يستهزئ بزي العلماء ولا يستهل هؤلاء
شعار الامه شعار المسلم
قد يكون فيهم دخيل نعم
وجاء عن عمر
وبعض العلماء يصححوا الحديث اخوف ما اخاف
على امتي منافق عالم اللسان صحيح هذا كلام
صحيح ومعناه صحيح لكن هل هذا الاصل ولا
هذا الطارئ
الجواب هذا الطارئ والا في الاصل
يحمل هذا العلم من كل جيل عدوله هكذا جاء
في الحديث اهل العدل هم الذين يحملون هذا
العلم واذا
نبغ بينهم نابغه في عين الناس وهو على
ضلاله فان العلماء يردون عليه
ويكسحونه ويقبرونه وبدعته ولا يدعون احدا
يدخل ويتجاوز هذا السياج على هذا الدين
هذا شغلهم
احفظونا كل شيء من هذا الدين حتى لو اتى
في احسن صوره
واراد ان يغير
حرفا واحدا من صحيح البخاري
لا افطن الله سبحانه وتعالى له
بعض علماء هذه الامه هذه امه مجيده كذلك
نقرا كثيرا
وهذا تاثر بغير المسلمين يعني اذا اتينا
مثلا نحن هنا في امريكا
الديانه الشائعه
النصرانيه مثلا
وقد خرجت فضائح
لبعض الفضائح الكبيره
للكنيسه صح ولا لا فضائح رسميه
حتى اصبحت وصما ومضرب المثل
فيظن الظان ان هذه كهذه فيلبس علماء
الاسلام امثال هذه الاشياء
فيقول
فظنه بالعلماء انهم اصحاب اكل واصحاب شرب
واصحاب
لهط مصاري الناس
وانهم يبيعون دينهم بارخص ثمن وهكذا
هذا كلام غير صحيح
ويجعل الاصل في اهل العلم الجهل
والتقليد الاعمى
فياتي الى اشياء ويقول ايوه العلماء يعني
شو العلماء كلهم وبعدين صحيح البخاري شو
هالكتاب اللي الناس مقدسينه
انا بقول لك البخاري في كذا وكذا وكذا
وكذا انا رايت واحد والله العظيم ما
تصدقوا
احد هؤلاء الجهال طلع على فضائيه في دوله
كبيره اكبر دوله اسلاميه عربيه
فطلع فيها
وعندنا عنده المقدم والفاصل والمش عارف
ايش
وهالاغاني والمعازف الدخل المعادي على
هالموضوع يعني
زخرف القول
ايش الحلقه هذه هذه الحلقه في خصوصيه ان
صحيح البخاري لا يعتمد عليه هذه عنوان
الحلقه
وهذا الدكتور الازهري المش عارف ايش الاصل
في الازهر هذه مدرسه مجيده عظيمه من اقدم
مدارس الاسلام لكن من كثر طلابه يخرج منهم
من ليس بذاك ومن كثر كلامه يقع في الخطا
وهكذا هذه طبع البشر
لكنه انا اذكر هذا لانه يلبس على المسلمين
بهذه الاهليات يقول انا درست في هذه هذا
هذه المدرسه لا تتبنى ما تقوله انت لكنه
يلبس هذه المدرسه ويلبس على الناس
فانظروا الى الجهل المفرط جهل مفرط قال
اول شيء
الناس بيقولوا البخاري البخاري
اصلا البخاري
ما كتب هذا الكتاب اصلا
والبخاري اللي بقولوا هذا الكتاب ينسب
اليه كان رجل اعمى في بخاره لا يحفظ الا
مش عارف ايش القصه هاي لا ادري اين اتى
بها وقال الصحيح
انه صاحب هذا الكتاب
اسمه جمعه
جمعه محمد ادريس
جمعه محمد انا استغربت من جمعه محمد ادريس
هذا منين اتى به لا اذكر في كل دراستي في
كتب
في كتب
الرجال احد الرواه حتى اسمه جمعه هذه هذه
التسميه حديثه اخر مئه سنه صار الناس
يسموا جمعه او خميس هذه اشياء ما كانت
منين جايبه جايبه من الغلاف لانه الغلاف
الكتاب مكتوب عليه جمعه
جمعه يعني فعل ماضي جمعه محمد ابن
اسماعيل
بس اسمه ايش جمعه ما انت مش عارف تقرا
الغلاف قلنا ليته
وبعدين يدخل لك فيه اشياء وكلها مبنيه على
ماذا على سوء الظن وتقليد غير المسلمين
واخذ شبهات الكفار ووضعوا تلبيسها على
المسلمين وصب ايات انزلت في الكافرين على
المسلمين وهكذا اصل البدع والضلال هو هذا
وكذلك قد يسيء احدنا الظن بالعلماء حينما
يستفتيه يستفتي العالم
يسالوه فلا ياتيه المفتي بما يهوى او ما
يستطعم فيذهب
ذهنه الى سوى الظن اما انه
ليس بذاك في العلم وهو ليس عالي الكعب في
هذا العلم طيب لما استفديته اذا
او يذهب ذهنه الى انه مقلد يقلد كلام
العلماء ولا يتمحص او انه
يعني صاحب رشوه فاذا
انه يعني يرتشي
بالفتاوى وصحيح ان هذه قد تقع قد هنا
للتقليل في اللغه قد يعني هل في عالم في
تاريخ الاسلام ارتشى نعم يكون هذا لكن هذا
النادر اله حكم في الشرع
نادر لا حكم له صح ولا لا
فنحن نبني هذا على سوء الظن
وهذا السوء يعود الى النفسيه يقول
ابو الطيب المتنبي وهو
بيت معروف لدى العلماء يكررونه في شرح
مسائل تتعلق بالظن اذا شاء فعل المرء
ساء ساءت ظنونه وصدق ما يعتاده من توهمي
هذا الكلام صحيح معناه صحيح
اذا شاء فعل المرء ساءت بنونه الحرامي بظن
الجميع حرامي
لذلك هو شايف الدنيا من هذا المنظر شايف
الدنيا من هذا من هذا المعيار من هذه
العدسه ينظر الى جميع الدنيا
هو لا يرى اشياء الناس الا
فريسه له فهو يظن ان الجميع ينظر الى
حاجته بنفس النظريه وكذلك الكذوب يظن ان
الجميع يكذب ويظن بنفسي انا اكذب اذا
كان هذا موافقا لهواعي فهو يظن الكذب في
الجميع ويظن الذي يدفعه ولا يدفعه الا
المال فانه يظن الجميع لا يدفعهم الا
المال
وهلم جره لذلك يقول اذا شاء فعل المرء
ساءت ظنونه
وصدق ما يعتاده من توهمي وهذا كلام صحيح
فحسن الظن يبتدئ بماذا بالنفس كيف الله عز
وجل يقول
ويقول في الذين وقعوا في القول في
المؤمنين ما ليس فيهم
لولا ظن المؤمنون
والمؤمنات بانفسهم خيرا
الانسان لماذا عبر الله بانفسهم خيرا لانه
كان المفروض يظن بنفسه الخير ويظن بالمؤمن
باخيه الذي بجانبه يظن به الخير انا احاول
انا انسان بحاول الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم علمنا
علمنا علمنا
التوبه ما هو الاستغفار اللهم انت ربي
وانا عبدك
وانا على عهدك ووعدك ما استطعت يظن ذلك
بغيره من المسلمين
وانا على وعد وانا على عهدك ووعدك ما
استطعت واخي كذلك
وان وقع في شيء فانني ارده واعدله بالتي
هي احسن ولو كنت فظا غليظ القلب لانفض من
حولك
ولا ازدريه
واقول كما قال الله كذلك كنتم من قبل فمن
الله عليكم هكذا فكر المؤمن السليم
واذا اوى الى فراشه قال اللهم
اللهم طهر قلبي من يعني اللهم لا تجعل في
قلبي غلا للذين امنوا هكذا النفسيه التي
لقنها الله سبحانه وتعالى ايانه على كل
حال ان شاء الله نكمل غدا والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد